[Music]
hi
i'm jessica lawson one of the view from
the top student leaders
on behalf of the leadership team thank
you for joining us
today we are excited to bring you yet
another outstanding speaker
to inspire us all as future leaders and
now it is my pleasure to welcome dean
levin to introduce our guest
it's a pleasure to welcome sonia singal
the ceo of gap to view from the top
today
sonia is a stanford alum she received
her master's degree from the engineering
school in 1995
and has worked its own microsystems for
motor company
before joining the gap where she was
i has been for more than 15 years
including as the president ceo of old
navy
and became the ceo of gaff just at the
beginning of the pandemic
and it's a great pleasure to have her
back to stamford and really looking
forward to hearing
about guiding the gap through the last
year and her career
and i commend to all of you if you have
a chance to read the wonderful
leadership profile of sonia that was in
the wall street journal
this last weekend it's really a nice
insight
into the year that she's had in such an
important role
so great pleasure and looking forward to
today's conversation with adrian negros
nba 2021 we are always so grateful to
have alums back with us
thanks for joining today it's good to be
here adrian
nice gap t-shirt too thanks for that
appreciate it
you know sonya there's a lot i want to
talk about let's just dive right in
learning more about you and your family
it became very clear to me you had their
support
forever your mom recognized your natural
creativity
your design skill your father said sonia
you can break any barrier out there in
the male dominated corporate world
that sounds like a pretty unique
upbringing to me could you tell us more
about it
sure uh listen i i it's you know my
passion for fashion started at a very
young age you're right i was 12 years
old
i was five foot seven and 95 pounds
and nothing fit so for me it was a
necessity
born of our invention board of necessity
i we didn't have a lot of money i
had to make my own clothes so that i
felt good and what i wore and
my mother was amazing driving me around
montreal to any fabric store that i
wanted and
really enabled enabled that creativity
um
in addition one of the things i'm really
grateful for for her
is she made sure that i could
be highly functional in any room and she
insisted
that um you know every weekend
we socialize with with her friends and
and
family and other people that just
happened to wander through our house
and it was an expectation that we would
talk engage with adults from a very
early age and
as i've walked into all the various
scenarios this year that's been
quite helpful so her then my father
really just
expecting us to do my sister and i
to reach whatever height we wanted and
that really being the expectation
through education
which is what brought me to stanford
incredible i love that and i'm excited
to talk about you socialize with people
older than you we'll get back
to that in just a second so sonia for
actually right now
i mean kettering university right that's
where you go to college
and it's in michigan well known for the
automobile ceos it produces
and you start at ford and you're 21 or
so with your pencil in one hand and
clipboard and the other on the night
shift
ask to evaluate the productivity of 50
to 60 year olds
so could you tell us about that yeah
that was you know i whenever i think
what was the hardest job i ever had to
do
i think of that job so this job is a
piece of cake relative to that one
um you know union shift union workers
midnight
shift um and my job was to make them
more productive some you know a 21 year
old
fresh engineer that really didn't know a
lot
and uh that was fun you know you realize
that connecting with humans at a human
level
laughing together um you know is really
the source of unlocking
value did i discover any opportunities
sure maybe a little bit here and there
but
um relating to the the working
um people on on the shift and then
observing very closely observing how
work was done
was what made me successful in that
moment and uh
and it didn't get a lot of sleep so it
was midnight shift so there's that
yeah and i think you know you're right
you've called those the boiler room jobs
before
i think it's where we really learn a lot
about ourselves yeah and i think listen
um i'm a big fan of getting your hands
dirty
and investing your personal time and
your careers
um you know where value is inherently
created
uh in this world and so for me i've
always been drawn
to that to making things to creating
that value to observing
that and to me uh tied to the making of
things
watching product at scale happen in the
auto industry
was incredibly stimulating exciting so
much
complexity and uh that was one of the
many jobs that i did there
at this time sonia you also recognized
you can't be
what you can't see what do you mean by
that and how did it maybe influence your
decision to move out west
i think kettering was an incredible
education i had you know as a co-op
program for five years i worked 10
different
roles in the bowels of a large
fortune 500 company at the time ford was
at its top in market cap
in its history when i was there so much
to learn but i stepped back
and i looked up and
the entire executive team were largely
white largely male
the entire board saying and the calculus
that i made was
do i want to work through all that or do
i want to go to sunny california i knew
i want to go to graduate school anyways
and so all the grad schools i applied to
were
on the west coast uh and
that's how i ended up here was making
that decision to move to the light
sonia you said you started at stanford
of course on the west coast i think we
have a picture to show
everyone oh god i hope you're okay with
this
could you tell us what's happening here
yeah so this was
one of the uh courses that we were
taking
in is the objective here was a race
around the quad
and we were in partner teams and we had
to make
this vehicle of using materials that
were predescribed and
whoever got there fastest around the
quad one
so um you can see me in the middle there
with my partner
on the left and we came in second so not
quite
satisfying and i think it is a gap
sweater that i'm wearing in the 90s so
there's that
although my fashion sense there is leave
something to be desired
but that was a fun moment again
engineering you know
you look around and what's obvious is
um you know
you know continuing to work in in a sort
of a high male
90 male dominated industry whether it
was auto
or tech has always been a feature of
my early professional uh time and it was
very forming as well
so an example of that here
exactly and sonia i also heard from your
team you met your husband on your very
first day at stanford is that true
i did the best thing that came from
stanford was that i met my husband
and um that i
you know you leave with this sort of
complete freedom to believe anything is
possible but let's start with my husband
because that's
hands down the best yeah we met at the
welcome picnic the night before
and um you know i showed up with my
pencils all sharpened and my schedule
all laid out and all ready to go
quite organized and he showed up um
having flown in from traveling and
trekking around the world for the last
four months
with a goatee in his birkenstocks and um
literally had flown in the night before
so quite different
but um i guess opposite the track and
really where we
connected was i mean certainly all over
campus but our shared values i think we
really discovered how similar we were
in that in one of our classes
ambidextrous thinking
which was a fun class at the time
it's incredible and to all the students
listening love is out there
be patient be kind it might just happen
on the stanford campus
and as my mother tells me the most
important thing the most important
decision you make is who you partner
with and so
um i consider that my ultimate stanford
success
absolutely completely agree sonia you've
been on the west coast for a while now
you're at a decade with sun microsystems
and then join
gap inc let's do it let's talk about
gapping for a little bit
it's close to home right it started in
1969 when don
and doris fisher are selling levi's
jeans and records
and thus don says let's call this
company pants and discs
i think that's super trendy in 2021 what
are your thoughts sonia well
well let me get to that but i will say
when i was at stanford
graduating i attended a view from the
top and
heard scott mcneely speak and
joined sun microsystems for a decade
because of that
and you know uh it was a a wonderful
decade for me motivated by his
inspiration
and for me really that what that taught
me was
um think big really think big you know
but then you know when i joined gap very
deliberate for me
going back to what really um
turns me on personally you know and what
what do i really connect with and
and fashion at scale was something that
was right and then
as you said uh the early years of gap
what a legacy
that i have to to honor right and
and don and doris at the beginning
founded this company
in 1969 they each put in 21 000
of their respective monies and thank god
doris
uh took over the naming of the company
because you know
uh pants and discs versus it started as
the generation gap
and then uh truncated to the gap was
really much more compelling and captured
the zeitgeist at the moment which
doris did gotcha so you're not
pants and disc isn't coming anytime soon
so we can sell
pants and we can play music you don't
have to call it that
gotcha makes sense so sonia your first
role
at gap inc was for old navy or not your
first role but you most recent role
rather was for old navy
and as dean levin said you did an
incredible job there
growing the business from seven to eight
billion dollars their motto starts with
imagine that the world runs right how
did you help old navy run right
so you know i think old navy plays a
special part in people's lives and and
uh it's a brand that was begun to give a
respectful
and aspirational environment and
clothing as a result
um where there was no compromise for the
value sector you know before then you
could only shop for your clothes
at kmart or or what have you and my
husband used to tell me like when he was
young his mother used to have to drag
him there and he was so
embarrassed by having to wear those
clothes to school
and the whole objective of old navy was
pride
and respect for these family for our
families and
you know that's what imagine if the
world runs right is it
everyone feeling included everyone
feeling welcome
and taking old navy from 7 billion to 8
billion
was sharpening our focus
on that differentiation making sure that
came through
in the branding in the products that we
offered
and being relentless in no compromise
around fashion
around the fun of the brand the family
essence of the brand
and the value that that brand created so
you know i stepped back and looked
around and i felt like okay our strength
at the core needed a little bit more
focus so we did that
and then we had the ability to grow the
brand through expansion both digital and
stores
that we did um while i was there
talk about kind of sharpening some of
the points around
old navy inclusivity for one you know
gaap was founded to do more than sell
clothes right
it's kind of in your dna to create for
all and be created by all to design for
all and
be designed by all you said in previous
interviews you don't want the gap in
legacy to be a flash in the pan moment
you want to really embrace inclusivity
and live it every day
so now as ceo of all the brands how do
you think about making sure that happens
yeah you know for all of the assets and
the values that we've had as a company
we also work we're a company that needs
radical change so that we can uh take on
the next 50 years on a with a with an
acceleration towards growth
and as i reflected on the past 50 years
and
and think about the next 50 at this
juncture that's really what i think
about and
while we had all these attributes we had
great founders great legacy great values
great brands
we didn't have the singular clarity
of why this company exists so the the
work that i did in the first year in
addition to
losing 70 of my revenue um at the height
of the crisis and burning 140 million of
cash a week in those early years
in those early days was declare
what do why do we exist what is our
company purpose
and so as a team we landed on that we
landed on we are inclusive
by design as our north star we
articulated that
and that's given us a great business
focus
great great business focus and to make
our decisions and
and whether they're small decisions or
big decisions so
great legacy just needed a clear
articulation
which we did absolutely and i think
looking at your leadership team right
eight out of 12 are women
people of color represented to me kind
of thinking about
the four days that you can't be what you
can't see
seems like you're you're executing it
right now at gap inc
well part of it is just good business
sense i mean we want to reflect
customers our customers our customers
are 75 female
er we reflect uh the diversity of
america
and we want to have that empathy and
that understanding
and that diversity of thought such that
we can best service our customers so to
me
um looking for that
differentiate different points of view
but in reflection of who we're serving
our customers
was an important step for us to take
personally i really appreciate that
sonia i think a lot of companies
organizations
want to do that again it's so cool to
see gap inc execute
i want to talk about something you kind
of mentioned about looking 50 years
forward
you've talked about risk taking a lot we
had satya nadella with us last year for
me from the top and his partying advice
for the mba students was
to be bold and to be right if you're not
bold
nothing cool will get done and he said
if you're not right you're not gonna be
around too
long to see anything happen period so so
where is gap being the boldest
and hopefully right and so i talked
about our why we exist as a company
um we all you guys have all taken the
class i'm sure around culture
eats strategy for lunch right so the
most important thing
is defining your cultural tenants for a
company
uh the number one one we've said is
we've staked our future on is create
with audacity
so creating with audacity is really to
signal
this idea of boldness this idea of
taking risks
you know and so um to me that's you know
that's going to be a big part of our
next chapter
and you know you're seeing that in some
of our decisions as we navigate
and move to acceleration absolutely
could you tell us more sonia about some
of the new initiatives the partnerships
the franchise agreements and how
perhaps those decisions may have not
happened just a few years ago
yeah listen i think uh at our core we're
best when we're at the zeitgeist of
culture
it's a little bit back to where um the
company was founded right we captured
this generational divide
that was happening in the late 60s uh
and
and anchored the company on that it's no
different today you know we're at our
best
when we're at this intersection of
culture and with the right products and
services so
as we thought about um this moment in
time and the partnerships
and the people whether it's a
partnership with easy
or a partnership with the largest
licensing company
that is part of our our calculus
is that's going to feed our crate with
audacity
it's going to extend the reach of these
brands that are known and loved
and are woven into american fabric
and it's going to allow us to expand on
both of those
dimensions super exciting i think all of
us consumers can't wait to see
what we can purchase in the next few
years at the gapping stores let's talk a
little bit about mentorship and
leadership sonia
so first thing on mentorship i think we
have a photo again this one isn't from
1995 i think it's more recent
this is yeah right yeah so that's doris
and i that's doris
one of our co-founders and aren't we
fortunate to have doris who also studied
at stanford
got her economics degree in 1953
co-started this company and
was very involved and i like to describe
doris as the heart of this company
not only was she smart enough to name it
right and was our first
head merchant but um she
is a woman who always spoke her mind and
that's what we all remember about her
in addition to the fact that she was a
mother
an activist a philanthropist
um and put everyone ahead of herself
um but always spoke her mind so she's a
great role model for me personally
and for all of us and we all stand on
the shoulders of those that came
prior um and she's you know she's one
that
of many that i look to for inspiration
incredible sonia i'd love to hear more
about mentorship i guess broadly
as well so have you thought about
finding mentors throughout your career
and maybe even today transitioning to
being a mentor for others
for me it's always been about what do i
need to learn
you know what do i need to learn where
am i and there's always things to learn
the mentors i have right now are
incredible
and um you know i'll always be seeking
them out
your first and most important mentor is
your direct boss
and people underestimate that that's a
very important
relationship to fully activate i've
gotten so much value over the course of
my career
from the direct boss relationship and
then of course there's mentors
that all want to help you know people
are really very very helpful
so um you know personally i've reached
out to
you know scott and i have he's been very
helpful tom mcneely who was the ceo of
my prior company
helping me right now as i think about uh
the work that i'm undertaking the
chairman of the board i've got
a mentor that i met through the catalyst
organization which is
an organization that's really about
accelerating women in leadership and i
met her 10 years ago
and really wanted to choose her because
she had complimentary skills to what i
had
and she was a marketing expert i didn't
have as much of that
so those are examples of how i've chosen
mentors
and then how i um choose the people that
i
mentor it's a tough one i mean i think
that
i'm personally drawn to uh
mentees that have a lot of fire and a
lot of ambition
and that perhaps i can help guide and
accelerate that
um but to me um you know i don't like
people that
are whiners i really have very low
tolerance for that so i i tend to choose
people that
can help themselves and that i can then
um hopefully give a helping hand too
for sure and i think sonya you mentioned
something that i think a lot of us think
about a lot
at stanford feeling uncomfortable asking
for help
and then maybe feeling like you're
invading on someone's time but
to what's what you just described you
know you can always give it back later
and
people they want to help everyone wants
to help it's really you knowing yourself
to know where you're where your gaps are
and to choose mentors that can
help you accelerate that gap and then it
becomes a very symbiotic relationship
i've always found that
i give as much as i get in both of those
um
relation on both sides of that
relationship it's wonderful advice
sonia i want to close by talking a
little bit about leadership
over this past year maybe than any other
ceo in the world you had quite a unique
situation you're named ceo of gap inc
late march of last year
all your stores then closed down as you
mentioned before
could you take us to those early moments
those first few days what were you
thinking how did you lead this company
yeah it's uh i probably could have ptsd
around it adrian at some point
but i will tell you in that moment being
named and then 48 hours having to
take 10 000 headquarters employees to
shelter in place and then
48 hours after that having to furlough
100 000
employees and losing 70 of our revenue
realizing we had seven weeks eight weeks
of cash
at the burn rate because of our fixed
infrastructure
um but you know
when i step back and maybe in that
moment of crisis
you everything becomes super clear you
know it's like that apollo 13 moment
you know when you just have to get it
done
and the situation requires
us to step into the leadership required
and so that's that's what happened and
you know you have to believe that we're
all here for a reason i was in that role
at that time
to lead and um
had to feel confident that the training
in my life
had made me ready for that and you know
humans are very very capable
they really are and so just confidence
and belief and focused on
the work was what got me through those
early days and then we quickly pivoted
you know
we got the largest bond offering in the
history of
uh retail because everyone recognizes
the value of the power of these brands
and as soon as we secured our liquidity
we quickly pivoted to offense
and um have not looked back and you know
declared our strategy
our power strategy and our growth
strategy and
we're off to the races so now i'm having
a lot of fun and
uh every day is fun and every day's
full of challenges but you know i'm
thankful that all of the experiences
that i've had over the course of
my journey um has prepared me as best as
anyone can be prepared
incredible i'm glad you're having fun
now i just saw your generation good
campaign yesterday
that sounds incredible super exciting so
glad we're back on the offense at gap
inc
yeah it's listen it's it's an incredibly
fun company and a fun internet
you know why did i chose why did i chose
get a choose gapping
you know for me the impact first of all
the fashion industry puts
more food on the table of families
around the world than any other industry
other than the food industry a lot of
people don't know that so for every job
i have 15 jobs come with it around the
world and
so that's one and then the other is you
know it is
highly technical 1500 engineers it's
highly creative
2000 artists and designers there's
workers in 30 countries around the world
we sell in 93 countries so the the
complexity and the impact and all of
these different kinds of people
is amazing and then also it's just fun
and cool like if anyone had told me that
i'd be meeting with president trump and
kanye within a four-day period
to transact deals i don't think i would
have believed it
um or you know or what have you but it
just happens
to be again back at the intersection of
what's relevant today
so yeah it is a lot of fun um yeah in a
daily basis
thanks adrian you mentioned president
trump khan i almost want to ask about
the conversations but i won't
i'll let my my classmates continue this
discussion sonia we have a couple
questions from the audience
i wanted to ask you how you navigate
being considered
an overrepresented minority while also
being the only female south asian
fortune 500 ceo
yeah you know i really struggled with it
at the beginning uh i was you know i
didn't want to be known as the minority
female ceo right and i was sort of
adamant about
that but it is inevitable because that
is what i
am and there's not many of us in fact
there's there's none as you
as you point out um or there's a couple
but
i guess uh and and by the way i'm i'm no
longer trending
you know rosalind brewer is now the new
one so it's great now people can just
evaluate me based on my results which is
which is what i would like
um so i guess i i moved into ease with
it over the year
started out sort of not wanting to that
to be the
determinant realizing though that it
also is an opportunity to
um inspire the next generation
and really for me though my ultimate
sense of self and
and sense of success is going to be
winning i am motivated by winning
i'm really motivated by winning and so
the benefit of that
is i get to stay in this job longer and
i get
a role model um hopefully uh the next
chap the next generation longer
hi sonia thank you for being here today
and thank you for giving us a little
window and
some of the challenges you faced over
the last year
question for you is how do you envision
the future of retail in a post code
or the physical retail stores in a
postcode world
yeah i think physical is really really
important you know humans are
uh five dimensions you know we've got
five senses and i would argue
six senses we've got the obvious five
senses and then we have the heart which
is our sixth sense what we feel
and um retails i mean
apparel in my sector but in general
retail large largely transacted 80
in a physical environment so sales are
generated
primarily the physical environment now
that physical environment
has to be relevant it has to be
differentiated i mean i've got
we've got the next generation that
pretty much only transacts on their
iphones
yet they crave experiences right um and
they will
go to want experiences so the obligation
on us is to create those experiences
that are relevant
that's going to change all the time i
think if we can
do that and we will the
it it maintains this premise that humans
go through the world
the physical world physical human beings
that interface is really really
important
it's incumbent on us to make it good
thank you i think there's something
exciting sonia about the physical store
still
i i always get excited when i walk into
a gap store i could probably never leave
without buying something so
as a consumer i think we're all excited
to see what kind of changes moving
forward
in that experience thanks adrian 86
of apparel purchases are emotional
purchases
so uh what your what you just expressed
is how i make my money for this company
and uh i appreciate that please go go
shop in more stores we need the revenue
which is why i have too many black
sweaters you can never have too many you
should see my closet
i want to close with our lightning round
on you from the top it's a tradition
are you ready for it i think so okay
so best date spot on the stanford campus
oh gosh um i'd say the dutch goose i
don't know if it's still there
but that's where we had many drinks uh
when
when we were there got it perfect
your favorite or best new quarantine
hobby slash skill
um cooking i mean i think i really have
embraced cooking i hadn't
hadn't done much of that in recent times
but it's very therapeutic
and enjoying it i completely agree
sonia could you tell us
the best piece of advice to leave the
stanford community
uh know yourself know yourself get your
hands dirty
i mean don't be the student
that is worried about creating the
wealth
get your hands dirty get in the muck and
um you know it's cliche but get in the
muck and follow your passion and know
that you can change the world
watching others or helping others do it
is not nearly as fun
agree so the last one is very easy none
of this
open-ended situation so i'm gonna give
you some options okay
so the best brand banana republic
old navy gap or athleta oh boy it's like
asking me to choose between my children
i sort of here's the way i would answer
it there's four characters in sex in the
city
as a woman we all relate to all of them
at any one given time
so i i have this theory that we're all
those four women
and so it's the same with these brands
we all affiliate with these incredible
brands
sometimes your banana public mind mode
when you're interviewing sometimes
you want to go feel free and you buy
that hoodie from gaap and
sometimes you take your family for their
kids clothes to old navy and sometimes
you gotta
really win on the workout field and you
put on athleta it
we're all all are important for sure
they're all incredible brands
sonia thank you so much for joining we
can't wait to see
what happens at gap inc over the next
few years under your leadership
thanks adrian
you